welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
abi dunn
who is the founder of 68 people
or also known as the hospitality
crusader
abby has worked in recruitment and
specifically within the hospitality
sector
for over 20 years and for the last two
years abby has been growing her own
recruitment business
that supports hospitality businesses um
across the north abbey thank you for
joining me
thank you very much for having me um
excited to unpack what it's been like
for a uh recruitment business owner that
serves the hospitality sector
but um where i want to start is in your
opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
um well i definitely think i've seen
people with different traits
be successful in different ways i think
for me personally um
it's about empathy and about totally
being able to understand how
somebody else feels whether that's a
candidate a client
you know anybody i think that is number
one
priority great recruiters can do that um
you know and i think maybe more
importantly what i i think is
is not a great recruiter and that's
somebody who's purely driven by
you know a placement of purely gym by
fee and i know that's probably
anti-recruiter isn't it but i think this
is
in my mind the best people that i've
worked with have got a really high
emotional intelligence
and understand uh
you know that kind of care and
compassionate side about you know
looking after them this is about
changing someone's life finding someone
a dream job
um you know solving one of the greatest
problems that your client might have so
i think it's somebody who sees it like
that as opposed to a a you know a piece
of data
um you know generally talking about
intelligence i think like memory plays a
massive role doesn't it we don't
talk about it too much but if you can
remember people i know we've all got
these flashy databases but
having a great memory is like right
genius definitely
yeah yeah yeah that's that's when i see
the difference between
kind of you know good recruiters and
great recruiters that you can just pull
from the back i can't i remember them
you know i remember them from years ago
and it also links into empathy because
if you remember somebody from years ago
you know you can make them feel good
about you know getting in touch going oh
do you remember when we spoke and
they feel great and you know it all kind
of connects together
um but yeah empathy for me is is
massively up there
interesting do you think
it can be just what you're talking about
in terms of
having an impact helping change people's
lives
do you think it can be you can like
recruiters can be just
be driven by that at the beginning of
their career because i think it does
evolve doesn't it like
and i think a lot of businesses if i
went into a recruitment interview
for a recruitment job and i just led
with yeah
yeah of course you've got to be um
you've got to understand your numbers
don't get me wrong you know i've worked
for businesses where
numbers come first and there's a there's
a part to place now you have to
understand where you are so that you
could improve you know there's no
getting away from that
you have to measure everything that you
do whether you measure the exp
you know the softer stuff on the
experience side and the quality of
of what you're doing or whether you're
you know just measuring
revenue but um you know so you have you
have to be driven
and motivated by a target completely but
i think
you know recruiters are a product of how
they've been managed and if you're
purely managed by that number
you will behave like that and you'll
behave and that's what's potentially
giving recruitment some of the bad
you know kind of reputation that it has
that that that historically people were
driven by
targets and revenue and um
you know at the cost of everything else
really yeah but
of course there has to be a combination
you know you can't we can't just be
you know nice lovely airy fairy people
skipping around
finding people jobs you know we've gotta
you know you've gotta you've got to
improve and and you've got to
measure everything that you do so that
you can improve
um you know a massive believer of that
and that's my entire career i was
i was lucky enough to to learn that
pretty early on that there's
you know what's the point in having any
kind of um
something to to work towards unless you
can measure its success
um and i think potentially it's where a
lot of companies may be outside of
recruitment
um you know don't do as well as they
could do because they put in these great
initiatives
but there's no measurements for success
in there um right
i also think they can't only be monetary
measurements you've got to have
other measurements within there as well
but yeah
so you so from what what i can see so
you've actually
you actually worked in the hospitality
industry before you entered
recruitment into hospitality yeah and i
do consider myself probably more a
hospitality person than
than i do a recruiter you know i have to
say
i started collecting glasses as a
student and
probably slightly reluctantly and then
and and grew with the business from
there and by the time i'd
graduated um ran uh
a site on a revolution actually on
oxford road
um and when i looked back now i think
god i was kind of 21 and they put me in
charge of this
you know kind of million pound turnover
business uh
you know that's that was um when i
looked better now i think crikey
i remember taking on like for example
taking on my team to
amsterdam which was very unwise um
and uh but but yeah so i've been a
hospitality person kind of
through and through and it got to a
point where i didn't want to
work weekends anymore i traveled around
the country with with inventive leisure
and um yeah almost got fired really for
not wanting to work weekends anymore
because that's
a prerequisite for for running bars and
then
and and luckily my hr director said well
you know if you go off and
and get some recruitment experience you
know we might be in a position where you
can come back and
recruit for us internally so i did that
i left and worked for an agency
in leeds called svb i had a wonderful
kind of
18 months with those guys and then um
went back into revolution as their
in-house recruiter so
and and i suppose that makes um
you know what you know i think it's
helped me so much to have that in-house
role
you know i've seen both sides of it and
i've seen how
you know that comes the budget
constraints of clients i've seen how
recruiters kind of can can approach you
and treat you and what i didn't like and
what i did like and that
you know has led to me creating
ultimately what you know
the business that i want to have now um
yeah
that's an amazing experience to
pick up and gather all that context so
you can really
view what you do and offer from the
client's perspective because you've been
in their shoes right so
that's that's amazing i guess what what
are the most common misconceptions about
working in hospitality
out of interest if you've been there
because for me it's like i don't know
i i one i respect anyone that does
because as you said it's
it's weekends it's it's really tough
work um
long hours on sociable hours
um i don't know what are the common
misconceptions about working in
hospitality
well i think i think even when i was you
know kind of a general manager of
these multi-million pound businesses you
know i still had
potential you know my family kind of you
know when you is this a real job i'm
like
yeah it's a real job um you know you are
you're an accountant you're a marketeer
you know you're a business manager
you're a people manager you're a leader
uh you know there's huge skill involved
in in in managing
any hospitality business but i think
there's a preconception that
you don't necessarily need a
qualification but i think that's a
positive thing you know
there is a direct route from bartender
to board level
without any qualification and um you
know that's pretty incredible and
i think the people within hospitality um
you know uh they they are kind of so
resilient they're
there's a lot of fun in hospitality a
lot of fun and
and you know historically i think people
who do come out of hospitality and
potentially try other sectors
it's a challenge because we're used to
dealing with these really kind of
high energy very positive uh and
actually very clever
people in into when i became a training
and development manager for revolution
and we did quite an interesting exercise
with some psychometric profiles
um and um my boss probably
still remembers this because it cost him
a lot of money but i i
persuaded him to kind of get all our
general managers
uh psychometrically profiled and
presuming that we'd find a behavioral
pattern between
managers and we were looking for you
know with presumably this kind of
influence our dominance whatever it
might be that we're looking for and we
thought we'd find compliance
and anyway we didn't find any behavioral
pattern between any general manager it
was all over the place
and but then we tested mental horsepower
um
and and actually then what we found was
there's a real
key correlation between high performing
managers and
mental health powers so there was where
people were doing really well they were
kind of 75th plus percentile in these
mental health protests so so it
i suppose my point is we proved it
wasn't necessarily about behavior it was
it was kind of
ultimately intelligence that was and it
sounds quite obvious but
you know that and there were so many
people within our businesses that were
you know they may be dropped out of
degrees or um
you know well i think that's a big part
in hospitality you kind of get into it
and then you drop
out of your you know chosen degree
because you found this great amazing job
with
an amazing team and you know you're up
all night working
and partying afterwards and then you
know you kind of
degree goes by the wayside but um but i
certainly
met the best people and and the most
kind of intelligent people in
hospitality for sure
interesting now that that's sort of what
came up for me i think probably there's
a perception that it's easy to get into
and there may not be highly skilled
people
yeah so okay so worked in recruitment
for
um yeah i just said 18 months then went
back into hospitality industry
and then left the hospitality industry
right
and then it looks like you you worked
for two different agencies over a
five-year period
so what what gave you the confidence
abby to to start your own recruitment
business i think
there's a lot of people that think what
have that that thought process of
well why can't i wouldn't it be great if
i could make do
these billings for myself um yeah
what what what gave you the confidence
to take the leap
um well
i suppose i need to say it was a very
difficult decision i worked with
um rory from from b recruitment and
you know we worked together for a lot of
years and it was kind of like a
self-employed i was set up as a
self-employed person so that's how his
business works and we work under kind of
his brand um and so i worked with him
for about four and a half
half years and it allowed me to have my
children
and and kind of have the flexibility
that i needed and i suppose it just got
to a point where
um you know i wanted to do something
around i wanted to be creative and
create a brand
um in terms of what gave me
the confidence i've always been someone
to
to take risks and i think you know i'm
very much on the
what's the worst that can happen um if
you know
what is the worst that can happen and i
at the time i had
three children and you know it
i suppose it was quite high risk because
you go from um
you know a fairly you know regular kind
of building and then you kind of start
again but
you know i built relationships up and
you know of course you make use of those
relationships but i think it is
what i've learned about anything from
having my own business you have to take
risks and you then
you know you kind of you know it's like
when you i went to a client meeting a
couple of weeks ago and
they were asking me if i could do
something and i've never actually done
it before but obviously my ultimate
answer was yeah of course and you know
you come out of the meeting and you're
like
okay let's work out how to do that now
but then that's what you do you know you
kind of build around it and you just
keep
you keep going and um you know i
i met two ladies when i first set up on
my own
um uh from a
um called katie green and and and nikki
who who helped who kind of set
they i went on one of their courses and
um i learned a lot about mindset and
um and they really really helped me i
did i did a program with with those
ladies and they were absolutely
fantastic and that they they certainly
helped me kind of
mentally just know that as long as i had
these things in place
you know then that's how you move
forward um
sorry again i was just gonna say that
that was me that was gonna be my
question for you i'd be like where where
did this mindset of
willingness to be uncomfortable say yes
then work out take risks come from
well i i i kind of think anything else
is boring
you know
you know i'm i'm really thinking right
now but i don't think i worry about too
much and
you know what what is the worst that can
happen and it's not as if i'm
financially supported by anybody
you know that's not my comfort blanket i
haven't got that
you know this is on me and if i [ __ ] it
up you know
the stakes are high um but i
i just have a belief that i won't um
and that is by maybe just saying it out
loud and then planting in your
subconscious that that's how you
believe um you know i i'd love to say
i've read loads of books
and i kind of meditate you know and i am
really bad at some of these things that
i was
one of the things i was worried you're
gonna ask me about is you know kind of
well-being stuff and all these
good things that people do like yoga and
meditation and
and i'm crap at that you know i really
am like i'm
you know i'm not good at kind of self
help or
or well-being and it's something that i
need to get better at um
but i have an unwavering belief that i
won't fail
i don't know what's going on my mother
that that's what
i think that's what really matters
though isn't it having that grounding of
yeah like whatever happens i'm i'm
really confident i can
make it work and um
don't get me wrong the last few months
of the last few weeks in particular that
has been tested
um but i think if you know
it sounds really cocky doesn't it but if
i can't do it nobody can in you know and
you know why would i be any worse at it
than anybody else you know
and i've been very lucky like you know
in kind of education wise and you know
have my mum constantly pushing me
um you know i don't i i know i'm lucky
and i'm very grateful
um for all that and and that's
definitely given me the confidence
i think that what i take from that which
i absolutely love is what you're also
saying there is like abby dunn
is completely responsible and
accountable to herself to make this
happen and
i love it my favorite principle is cause
and effect
and you know i meet all the time people
where the world is happening
to them and you know there's nothing
they can do about it
this is you know woe me i have people in
my own family like that
and i've never felt like that i i
believe that everything was in within
completely within my control and only
then
you know can i influence it and and do
something about it and um
that's hard to teach other people though
i think because you know
even my husband is not great at it you
know he's gets
frustrated by things and you know kind
of would be the first for
to to blame someone else for it
happening i'm like just take
responsibility come on
um hopefully he's not going to watch
this back
i think um no no you're right it sounds
really simple doesn't it but i think
it's actually really empowering when
when when you truly
believe that and you're right you can't
you can't push out and impose that on
people that isn't a way for them to take
responsibility sometimes and i've had to
learn this when
i've i've sort of come to my own
realizations that well actually
i'm in complete control of him i full
responsibility and then
if my girlfriend might have some of
those moments where she's pointing the
finger at
this or or something and then it's easy
for us to jump straight away with like
well
look what's the point in focusing on
that you can't control that
they don't need that sometimes yeah but
for me it's more about leading by
example
it's more about do you get what i mean
if if abby shows
like i'm sure over the last six eight
months he's been completely ignore of
how you've taken responsibility and you
could have
sat there and gone chronovirus this
government this and it's more about
sort of leading the way and and then you
have those moments where it's like well
look this is what i've been talking
about right take responsibility and
that's where you have sometimes
more of those breakthroughs rather than
every time they go
god say that person who's cut me off on
the traffic and when i'm driving
it's like well what's the point in
focusing on that yeah
to finalize that then like what what
advice would you give
abby dunn at the beginning of this
journey of starting your recruitment
business
knowing what you know now what would you
say to yourself
um
what would i say to myself i
i this sounds really bad isn't it but i
don't i don't look back and and have
things that i should have done
differently is that really bad i
you know i i i'm quite a positive person
as you might have seen and
you know i i did it's probably easy for
me to say what would i say to other
people
maybe because there's a couple of things
i did really well that was i didn't look
at what anybody else did
i didn't you know i didn't um
get concerned about competitors i didn't
they didn't even come into my sphere of
thought
at all and they don't um and that's not
arrogant that's just
i i feel better if i don't because and i
do start to maybe glimpse at what
someone else is doing i'm like
you know should i be you know and it's
not good for you it's not good for you
so certainly that and then you know what
i set up with this really clear purpose
and that is something that i think if
anybody is setting up
that would be what i i would advise you
know
people to come up with and to stick by
and to kind of
um to be unfaulted and that's um it's
helped me
certainly through the last you know six
months and and
the most difficult time of the last few
weeks more than anything um
yeah why does that help cause i think a
lot of people talk about the importance
of company values purpose but like
what how would you articulate like why
is that important and why has that
helped you
um i think it helps me know constantly
why i'm doing things and you
helped you make every decision it's easy
to make decisions in your business if
your purpose is really clear so
our purpose is to change lives to shape
the industry and
disrupt recruitment so there's three
elements to it one is basically kind of
candidate driven
changing lives and finding people great
jobs um shaping the industry is
the client part of it you know making um
recruitment
in our clients better by giving the
right people
and then disrupting recruitment is kind
of doing things you know that
might not necessarily be done before um
and it just
it just clarifies everything for us and
it it's um
and it makes it not about money and i
think that's
where a lot of recruitment businesses um
that you know or find it difficult i'll
come across
in my opinion um wrong because their
their their their purpose is
is making money and that's never been my
purpose that will be an output of my
success without a doubt
but it's never it's never at the
forefront of what you know it's never my
first thought
it's it's a it's a nice output
yeah it's for me what i've really
experienced in my short career so far is
that when you actually generally
what you're talking about when you
actually genuinely have a mindset of
giving more than you take yeah you end
up taking more anyway
yeah like because it comes to you right
so it's what you're talking about is
that well actually
when we actually have this really clear
north star it helps us make decisions it
helps us understand why we do it
and actually when we actually really
just focus on that the outcome of
financial supporting my family hitting
on targets
it's just a prerequisite it happens yeah
right definitely
yeah yeah 100 so
let's just talk a bit about for the next
five or so minutes around like
the first year right yeah because i'm
sure that
i mean like a lot of people going into
2020 right he says our year
gonna grow and what we've done for the
first year and then obviously
we've all been having to deal with
adversity so i guess how was that first
year for you then so you had the belief
you had a clear purpose um
how would you describe your first year
in being a recruitment business owner
yeah i mean i i loved it
you know uh we i possibly grew too fast
i probably added head count on slightly
too fast
there's one thing that i regret there
you go that's i probably grew
up grew a bit faster i got over excited
about
maybe having this bigger business or
having a perception of this bigger
business and i had an
added head count a bit too soon um
but you know from we set up in january
19
um and you know our sales built
month a month right up until february um
this year um and
so yeah it was all it was all great we
were doing kind of team events away in
the late district we were doing
you know we were being approached by
clients our
we were getting loads of comments about
our
marketing and um you know
it it was great the team were and they
are now but you know super super engaged
and you know that that was really
important to me and
you know and i think that one of the
you know some of the team came directly
from hospitality
and kind of so they were very junior
from a recruitment sense i either not
did it before
um and but that meant that you know we
had this team
team of quite junior recruiters but
actually who was so passionate about
what we were doing and
and had the right um you know the right
frame of mind and
and you know teaching people recruit
from scratch is actually
amazing it's it's it's hard work but
it's it you know it's amazing so
yeah we had a great a great time you
know we had a great first birthday party
and all was going swimmingly
what did you do revenue wise in your
first year um
well so it's for our first year we did a
um
for 400k um which
so i i suppose as an individual
recruiter i'd previously worked and
and not not being far off that i think
my last year as an individual recruit
before that
i dropped quite significantly i was
working from home i'd lost my kind of
mojo
um i don't even know how 400k compares
to other people
um i don't know whether that's good or
bad
no it's just good context for people but
i guess like
some of the things that i gave when i
was preparing for this was um
you really advocated that a lot of your
and
let me know if this is true but a lot of
your business has come through referrals
or recommendations right so you're
talking about people coming to your
marketing
you you've got right people involved
that have the right passion etc
yeah but so so sort of hearing about
getting referrals recommendations is
really common right for recruitment
businesses say look we grow by word of
mouth
but like in that first year um
and yeah up until your first birthday
like what would you say was the most
effective way of driving business
through referrals
um i said well i think
i had had relationships with people of
some existing relationships but also
um relationships that
i had taken from working for a company
like revolution you
you'd had so many people that had come
through there and then gone on to
set up other businesses so i was lucky
in that sense as well um
but i think we set up incentives you
know we set up incentives around
referrals
we we took we made a point of taking
testimonials at any point that we could
and promoting them um you know so if you
go onto our
our website or any of the information
that we send out to people
it has you know i'm a big believer in
kind of transparency and maybe to my
detriment i don't know but you know how
who our clients are and who who which
specific person within that business has
said this about this
um and we shouted out we shouted out
about that
um but i think yeah obviously referrals
was a part of it but i also think that
you know people just came to came to us
because we promoted a brand that
people wanted to be a part of and people
actually and we got quite a lot of phone
calls
wanting table bookings which for me was
fine because people
thought we were a restaurant and i was
like i'm cool with that if our branding
makes us look like a restaurant that's
fine um
and so i you know and i think we people
wanted to be a part of it and wanted to
to kind of hear more about what we were
doing um
so yeah and it obviously it feels a bit
like a long time ago because we haven't
operated
like that now since february and that's
probably the sad thing about it
yeah so just let's talk about what's
been going on
from february but just before we do yeah
i think
you may have may not seen this i mean i
saw one of the things that you met up
with sort of um
competition network of hospitality
recruited something assuming you've got
a bit of an insight but
um like how much like what what did this
strategy look like for building your
brand
as a recruitment business because i
think this has become more and more
important it's something that recruiters
don't know how to do themselves
yeah recruiters are actually way more
encouraged to be part of a recruitment
business that values marketing and
branding because they know how much it
can help
like what were the sort of maybe two
three core
things that you got right with your
branding that really helped that maybe
people could benefit from listening
i don't know how to strategy when i set
out but the things i i
am i got right i think it was
as soon as anybody starts selling to me
i switch off to it okay so that kind of
uh
traditional language even if and maybe
it's within hospitality
people don't want it or whether it's any
sector i don't know but
i couldn't bring myself to be calling
people and saying
so how you know how how's business you
know just
it doesn't feel natural to me and i know
there'll be people listening to this
going well that's what that's what sales
is
so i'm i'm sales to a certain
you know traditional selling techniques
you know the word selling technique in
itself that you know
it makes me quiver um
so i wanted to push i i pushed why we
were doing it
so i know it's you know famously simon
sinek's
back isn't it but you know i pushed why
we were doing it that's basically all i
did i pushed why we were doing it
and to some extent um how we were doing
i never ever pushed what we were doing i
never mentioned our database i never
mentioned
our process it's boring you know it's
really boring
so i i i pushed to you know our ways of
working we've got these eight ways of
working and
and i pushed out our purpose um and
i invested in like you know i i found
this um
a company called lit marketing and who
were starting out themselves
and so a lot of the branding and the
design work
um you know probably looks like we
invested a lot more money than we did in
it you know
we were paying you know we were kind of
getting some nice stuff designed and it
might have been 50 quid or 100 to quit
and it wasn't huge investments but it
looks great
and even me sitting on camera doing
something that looks [ __ ] so
you know just put an investment into
that we really
really looks good and actually people
have come to us and going who did you
design i'm like
it's that this lit marketing they're
brilliant aren't they um
you know and and i can't thank them
enough but they were you know they
weren't a big marketing agency they were
they were led by my my own creativity
but i couldn't do the design part and
but i knew what looked right and what
didn't so i think investing in that side
of it
um really helped i forgot what your
question was
no i really like that so no i really
like that it's back to
purpose why and lead with that from a
brand of perspective not
not yeah and obviously it's also helped
from you as a business owner perspective
and then i actually really like that
insight that actually
there are a lot of small growing
businesses out there
yeah try and try and speak to those in
good relationships there that actually
yeah it can work for both parties right
so so i actually really like that if
you're a business owner sometimes it's
easy to be like
oh i need all this like all um all bells
all
whistles marketing strategy and stuff
well actually there's probably a lot of
people out there that
are on a similar journey to you that
could probably help you on the marketing
side that
would mean that you don't have to invest
as much straight away so i really like
that
and i think we i put a lot of time
personally into our social media so our
social media account
until fairly recent was run by myself
and and i think that really helped um
you know so the tone of voice was ma
with me and i think as soon as you pass
it on to somebody else that can get
diluted and
i'm a big believer that if you're a
founder at starting a recruitment
business that
that should be controlled by you it
should be your thoughts and feelings and
that
um and and that helps set the entire
tone of voice in your business and
and that then you know we all speak the
same language in the business i
i think if i asked now anybody within
the team to take over the social media
they would write it
you know in in a way that reflects our
tone of voice as a business
um yeah and but i know it's sometimes
difficult as a recruiter to think
correct what have i got to say
about recruitment because it's quite a
dry subject matter you know
what what can i post on a grid every day
about recruitment i think that will be
challenging that's why
it's easy easier for us because we've
made it sector focused as opposed to
recruitment focus we do
talk about recruitment sometimes of
course we do but it's sector focused
um and putting that
kind of you know
my entire thinking about it all was that
this isn't
again wasn't about driving revenue and
wasn't about um
opportunity it was about how can we help
our sector how can we make
you know that recruitment better within
our sector and and that shows through
our
social media and that's helped us build
the brand
i love that so abby talk
share with us what you was feeling and
what
was going through your mind when
february started to happen and
because at the beginning of this like
for me personally i had um
so i had a live podcast event lined up
in march um over 200 people paid to go
there
i remember having those conversations
where it was
i sent an email around like who who is
who is um who's not going to come
because of this covered thing
right and then that drastically changed
within the week
right in terms of the messaging from
everyone blah blah so
like just start by going there like
what would you like how did you feel
what was going through your mind when
you started thinking oh my god this
isn't a two-week thing which a lot of us
thought it might have yeah
yeah i definitely didn't see it coming
and i definitely i think i took
um it hit me when i had one client phone
call
um and the the recruitment manager said
look i'm sorry we're not going to pay
this invoice
um until like this all settles down and
i was like
what why you know what you're talking
about
and obviously and then i suppose
it just seemed to happen so quickly then
that it was phone call after phone call
after phone call
you know of clients changing plans check
you know so
within i'd say 48 hours and well
what we've done it was the northern bar
show as well and we'd um
it was they were on the edge as to
whether this was going ahead or not
going ahead so we'd actually
um put in furniture into the show we'd
got all our stall
set out um and then literally it was
pulled very last minute the day before
so then i was like that's you know these
big guys are pulling stuff
and we so we and it wasn't just the fact
that
future work was cancelled within this
48-hour period it was that
candidates that had already started were
being let go
um you know candidates that were
currently in process
all fell away and then anything for the
future fell away so
and this is pre-furlough scheme so you
know i kind of we kind of sat there and
um you know very sadly uh and i i've got
i've got super emotional about covered
once and this was on
um in in in march when
it was just so shocking you know we were
all just so like
what the hell because the business had
gone from this
you know we'd had one of our best months
in february our best months
and then got dropped to nothing um
in march was just so bizarre
and we all sat around the table and kind
of all crying and weirdly enough our
contract for our office we were moving
offices and
it was to end on the 31st of march so
not only were we
kind of sat basically dissolving the
business
um we were packing up the office
physically as well so it was like the
most depressing day ever
and there wasn't a fellow scheme so you
know so
as everything cascaded suddenly i was
like right okay we've got no jobs
no candidates no no one paying invoices
this is
this is laying off people immediately
you know this
you know what what it wasn't a big
enough business to say okay we can
pay salaries for three months um
oh and that there's another regret i
should have saved my money as
um when he said what would i reflect
back on it i should have saved more
money and
you know built up a bigger buffer um
but yeah so so much kind of changed to
everything and
um yeah that was the the rest is history
on that and
i think within hospitality it's
you know you obviously you've got to
have a certain amount of fight and our
fight was
directed into helping the sector because
we couldn't really help ourselves you
know
whatever anybody's listening to somebody
may think if the if everybody's
letting people go everybody the good the
bad you know everyone
um the opportunity for recruiters is
isn't exist you know it doesn't exist
really it's not as if
you know you sell hardy and you find
those
opportunities there wasn't any
opportunity it was completely hibernated
um until july when browsing restaurants
reopened
and lo and behold you know we had um our
september revenue was back to our
february revenue
um so we had this real lovely sense of
oh this is
this is going well um and then
um obviously it's dropped off a cliff
again sadly but
like i said to to the the emotion that i
felt about it in march
and become numb to it now because you
know
i don't and i know we spoke about cause
and effect and being able to
um make sure you have influence but this
is this is a bugger you know i can't
this is again suddenly everything's
going how do you have a
you know no revenue then your best month
there but then no revenue like you know
yeah
healthy and then so what i'm taking
so what i'm taking from that then is
yeah
obviously like we all went through
really emotional what like how can this
happen
what the hell is going on processing it
basically like is this real life we've
got boris johnson on the telly
i feel like i'm in a video game like
what is it what is going on right
and then so then so the way you took
responsibility was
right recruitment let's put that aside
for a second because as you said the
good bad the ugly they're letting people
go there's an opportunity there what
let's channel all our energy into
into helping our industry um
why didn't you quit why didn't you go
right i'm just like because a lot of
people would have gone
yeah i'll wait until this blows over or
like you said firstly
seems like maybe didn't have the
financials for you to go right i'm just
going to put my feet up and spend time
with the kids for the next
three four months but like why didn't
you quit abby
um i think i i felt as i had a bit of a
duty to
people to you know to show strengths and
to show positivity and to show
innovation and again that sounds a bit
knobbish but i meant to our candidates
really because they were
um you know going losing jobs left right
and center
and you know we wanted to show okay
right let's
let's help and let's um and kind of show
what we're made of really and so
you know we adapted the business um
to you know to supporting the industry
and
and you know that's i it's helped
it's helped keep me sane certainly um
because i felt i've had some purpose
during that time
um you know because we haven't taken any
of it we've
started people we started building
revenue again from july when people
started paying all the invoices but that
whole time in between no revenue
um uh so from recruitment you know
we pivoted and and looked at thing you
know i delivered lots of training to
people
and so we did uh we kind of
ran mentoring schemes there was other
little bits of revenue that we took but
nothing that could
you know compare to what we've been
billing previously
um but yeah certainly i i felt as though
not only we didn't have a duty but we
also had the ability to
bring people together because we had
relationships with a lot of people
across the
city you know specifically manchester
and
you know we had relationships with lots
of clients and so
you know we could have that influence um
you know one of the we did lots of
different things
obviously one of the the greatest things
i'm really proud of is the no more no
shows campaign um
you know which so just talk about that
for a sec because i wrote and a question
around that so
do i just want to highlight generally
like i i think it's amazing again you
really showcase your
your mental resilience there where and i
think this will do
yeah i think it'll make or break people
this period right where you've gone
straight to
what can we do to serve okay well what
other things can we
offer our clients and our network that
is centered around them if that's
mentoring if it's training if it's
putting people
together right but yeah so i i
definitely wanted to ask you about that
so like it looks like you've
you've been you've you've given
hospitality a voice
or you've tried to give hospitality a
voice right which i think is amazing
outside looking in but one of the
greatest things that
you're proud of as you just said is that
no more notions just give talk us a bit
about that how that came about and what
impact it had
um so i've seen a tweet from a friend of
mine antonio who works for gusto
restaurants and she tweeted about them
when people had gone back uh to
restaurants i think they had 6k
of um no show book and no people no
showing that weekend
uh and i thought that is you know that's
horrendous after the journey that people
have been on
i delivered all these traits these this
manager training
and just you just knew what these guys
were going through they were nervous
they were you know there was so much
going on
for them but they're excited as well and
to set up for service
and and have everything ready to go and
then to have people no show
you know when you're reduced capacity
anyway it was just horrendous and i felt
really
passionate about you know about saying
to customers you know what the hell are
you doing you know this is not cool
we knew that we couldn't have a client
or a
um a client facing campaign because we
couldn't
influence that the technology that we
use or the process that they use but we
could influence customers
um so i remember i think we were allowed
out and
stuff for that time i remember sat in
the the boozer little boozer at the back
of albert schloss and coming up with the
artwork with some friends and
um you know antonio and i met and knew
that knew that the message would have to
be really simple
um we had a conversation that said look
if a hundred people share this title
which was three steps um you know rebook
and and you know we still love you um
but make sure you let us know um and
we thought if a hundred people share
this then we've done our our job
um so we did it in the thunderclap style
so we we asked
um kind of operators
and hospitality people in the sector to
share this tile at one specific time at
10 o'clock
and one one morning um
and at the same time i think luckily for
us you know celebrity chefs were talking
about no shows so tom carriage was
talking about it
um and you know simon was talking about
it so it was kind of like a perfect
storm
but the beauty of being a recruiter in
it which you
don't see very often maybe but and was
that
it wasn't another company you know we
didn't put our branding on it
um which i think was the reason it was
so successful
but we also didn't we weren't another
company you know
if an operator had come up with this um
idea like for example antonio from gusto
if it was gusto's idea that would have
been very difficult for other operators
to get behind it so the fact that it was
a third party
um uh you know was great and i'm really
proud of the fact that we didn't put our
branding on it
because actually then we might not have
got some of the press that you know but
i don't think it would have been a
successful
you know in it we ended up people shared
the title
um and it couldn't have gone better in
terms of the results of it i think we
had 12 and a half million twitter
impressions
you know we have a billboard you know
the bank put billboards up for his uh
sorry he put a massive piece up for us
in manchester and one of the high um
one of the um i can't remember the
building name but
um we got 450 billboards across
manchester and london we had a double
page spread and the observer
we were on bbc we were on channel five
we were on challenge
so it was it couldn't have gone better
as far as a campaign and actually
my friends who work in marketing were
like how much did you spend on this
campaign
and um i think it's 450 quid on you know
work and they were like oh my god you
know this is this is unbelievable
and you know we had an influence and i'm
so proud of it
um you know we and i think you know we
whether it was temporarily or not from a
recruitment perspective made that move
from recruiter into you know a voice
that should be heard in the sector and
you know that's what i always want to do
and um i don't think it's easy for
recruiters to do that
and but that's you know we did that with
that campaign which was
you know great and i'm really proud of
it yeah i remember saying that i think
that's um
amazing and i think that's obviously um
one of the most amazing things about the
world we live in today social media gets
a lot of bad
press um but also at the same time
when it's for good it it can it can
generally have a rule and patch
really quickly and it can reach millions
of of people
and so look what i'd love um for you to
share then
so like what what have been like your
personal like biggest challenges than
that be so we've spoken about how you've
pivoted
you've sort of channeled your energy but
like for you personally what
what's been your biggest challenge i can
imagine that you've got to be abby dunn
the
the hospitality crusader you've got to
show up for your team and then you've
got to be
on point mum as well for free kids and
your family that must be difficult
like how what been the biggest
challenges for you
um yeah i think
when you've got it when everything is
going on in terms of the kids and
homeschooling and
you've got it all kind of coming
together it's difficult to be
to know whether to be kind of average
everything
or be great at home schooling and not
great at work or be great at work and
not great you know so
that was difficult you know finding that
balance
certainly but um i think the
you know the the last few weeks have
probably been the toughest way where
it's
where the revenues dropped off again and
you kind of feel as though
god have i got any fight left have you
know i thought and
i don't think you can argue with the
fact that i i i
i thought from every angle and
to then you know to then be affected by
the curfew to then be affected by tier
three where we're in now um
it's very it's difficult it's difficult
to you know i've had to let some of my
team go and that's been
you know horrendous because i made them
a promise and i've not
i've not been able to keep it and that's
the the saddest thing about
it you know i kind of went into march
thinking about whatever happens
especially when we had the furnace game
um you know we'll
we will get through this i sent them
cards during lockdown saying we'll get
through this i sent them
bonsai trees you know and you know
that's not i've not been able to do that
so that's
very very hard um and it is
you know as much as all this sounds
quite positive i
i'm not 100 sure whether you know this
business will survive this you know the
next few months it's very
unfortunately i am you know at the mercy
of
government regulations and i'm not
trying to blame somebody else for that
but i you know if hospitality
doesn't open or doesn't take revenue
then i don't have a business either
um and but i'm also very
kind of pragmatic about that and in fact
that okay well you know we might have to
consider making some very tough
decisions early next year
but you know we'll come back as whatever
we might come back as or
you know that's worse worst case
scenario but
you know definitely just you you have to
just keep moving forward
um but yeah it's not it's not all rosie
and all these
wonderful things that's been happening
and it's been great but you know i have
to be honest and say
you know of course i'm of course i'm
worried about whether this business as
it exists the 68 people will
you know will get through the next few
months i'd be naive not to be worried
but
i still have the ultimate belief that i
will be successful in something
you know whatever that might be in the
future
yeah i love that and i have no doubt
either i guess
to sort of put that together what what
do you think is can
what sort of thing have you learned
either about yourself or your business
that you think will uh
stick with you in in 2021 and beyond
um well i really like writing i've
started
as a way to um kind of um
get everything down and maybe get it out
of my head i i started writing
kind of different articles and um
blog things and i've loved that so that
that's you know i didn't
i didn't think i was good at writing i
didn't you know
or wouldn't have thought that i was the
writer but i really really enjoyed doing
that and i've had some really good
feedback on it so
that's something i've learned um in in
this whole times
yeah you you can't find new things that
you you know you
you didn't know you're good at i love
that
so one of the things that i saw you
right
was and i think this rising quite nicely
around you being quite honest with us
and going look
i've i've given this a real good fight
but look
i can't be naive and we're going to face
challenges and we're going to do our
utmost to survive
but one of the things um that we spoke
about and this article was around
what you might end up doing is helping
hospitality professionals maybe not
going to hospitality
right unfortunately like because yeah
because
because these professionals again it's
i'm sure
you of course you can relate right it's
like well i'm a bit of a crossroads here
i've done everything i can to hold on to
my career in hospitality but
i need to put myself first and maybe i
do need to upskill myself or try this so
i guess the article that i saw i think
it was shared
i can't remember the exact outlet but it
was about
why hospitality professionals would
could be and why they could be amazing
hires
right and i've heard before obviously
like you said
when you've hired people for your own
business makes even makes even more
sense that they have the context of
working hospitality but
i've heard numerous times from a group
of business owners that
getting people from maybe hospitality
backgrounds is good they've got that
resilience they've worked long hours
those sorts of things but like why could
hospitality professionals be amazing
eyes even for recruitment businesses or
just in general would you say
yeah um well i think if anybody's
considering it
there's a podcast by um one of the tony
robbins podcasts that features danny
mayer
um who you know who owns a wonderful
restaurant business in new york
and he asks the audience um
is his interview maybe not a podcast but
he asks the audience um how many people
work in hospitality
and obviously only a few put a hand up
but he challenges them he's like no
you're wrong you know everybody works
hospitality
because actually hospitality is 49 of
what everyone does and you know making
people feel good
um is is is part of an accountant's job
it's part of a lawyer's job it's part of
everyone's job so with that in mind you
know
these guys are going to get to that
halfway mark before
before you teach them whatever technical
skills they might need
um you know that that service part of
something
and and and again going back to this
empathy of putting yourself in someone
else's shoes is what hospitality people
will
will absolutely nail um and you know i
think i mentioned in there
people are very positive in the sector
there's no you know we don't have
overtime we don't have
long-term sick we don't um you know
we we talk in a different way you know
we there's no i don't think you'd get
kind of complaints about things you know
very you know obviously there's
good good and bad in every sector but
you know if you make me a great
hospitality people
person the energy the positivity
that you know that graft is um you know
is amazing but certainly that service
part
let's face it exists in every sector and
you know we
should use hospitality people as much as
we can i love that
and look i don't to impose um i'd be
done turning the business into
hospitality right to wrap business but
if if anyone is listening and like they
want to connect with you and talk
like no doubt you will know some amazing
people that no doubt are having to
really
think about and reflect on their career
right so if you are listening right now
and go you know what
we do have growth plans and we have
taken on people from hospitals in the
background 100
get in touch with him whatever comes of
that comes that right
that's what i definitely encourage i
wanted to make sure we spoke about that
um
look i just i've got five final
questions for you
okay but i just want to say honestly i i
think it's amazing how you've approached
this and you've really showcased your
mindset resilience
um and from outside looking in i think
it's
amazing some of the things that you've
done to really give your industry a
voice which i think is one of the
amazing things that recruitment the
recruitment industry can do for their
sectors right
they know so many people they're so well
connected and recruiters have every
right to be that voice and that forum
that champions their industry yeah
so true yeah so i have five questions
for you
okay so the the first question is
if you could change the industry the
recruitment industry what would you
improve
um selling selling techniques awful
selling techniques
nice the second question
um if if you don't read that that's fine
we can work it out but what book have
you read that has had the biggest
impact on you well i do read i i did a
lot of reading it in my earlier career
but um
i would say from
probably seven habits i love seven
habits it's a go-to book
you know i've still got to find one
that's better than that yeah no
that is a really good book um this ties
into your
writing passion but if you could write a
linkedin post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant across the world
what would you want it to say um
every recruitment consultant in the
world um
oh i am to stop and i can't do it yeah
and i i'm working on it but just
let's stop the industry completely doing
any form of contingent recruitment
um if i could eradicate that and so that
nobody's doing any work for nothing
and um it'd be sort of a post around
that
i like it what did you spend
your first biggest commission pay check
on
oh
in my own uh when i was in the
agency crikey agency you're in business
what what comes to mind when you think
yeah i treated myself after
yeah i i would i spend
money on kind of experiences so holidays
and hospitality so yeah definitely
i am when when my husband and i go away
we sometimes go away with our in-laws
and
then they can babysit the kids while we
booger after somewhere even nicer than
we've booked for two days so
it'll be something like that with a you
know some kind of luxury two-day break
would always be what i'd spend any
commission on like it
and then final question is what what's
the ultimate goal
for your recruitment career um
to change the perception of that
recruiters have
in in my sector um i don't know it's in
every sector but
you know six to what i know um yeah i'd
love i'd love to come out of this
as like we said as a voice
for the sector and and and someone to be
you know
her heard rather than you know you're
just a recruiter and
that's what i'd love to kind of leave
you know when i retire that's what i'd
love to have done
amazing abby it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for having me
i've always
thank you